okay our first question is coming from
cami
um what is your question to demona i'm
45 i am single and i am so old school
where i am not approaching any man
i can be in a party and we will just
have a staring match and then we both go
home
what advice or what tips can you give me
demona on how to break out of that shell
and just go for it how the how how
cammy you're a you're an old school girl
living in a new school world okay
so i want to just set aside those
beliefs that that were probably passed
down to you from generation to
generation this is how it's done we're
in a completely different paradigm and
just starting a conversation with
someone that's not that is not a
marriage that is not a marriage proposal
that is not a commitment that's just a
conversation and you never know where
it's going to go so i really want you to
reframe any thinking around it being a
rejection so i actually i would give you
a little assignment to be
be a little bit brave and the next time
you're making eyes at someone go ahead
and initiate the conversation and see
what happens because the more you do
that cami the less weight you'll put on
each individual interaction and the less
anxiety and worry that will come up when
you go to talk to someone the next time
practice makes perfect right exactly you
got it in my practice thank you thank
you
i agree i agree with that a lot also i
really am having like a kind of an aha
moment because i am josie grossi and i
think that everybody can feel that so
when i go up to talk to a guy here's
what's happening on the inside
hi
but i think all they see is hey what's
going on
but they can't tell what is happening on
the inside but we think it's all out
there and he's josie grossi on the
inside too that's the crazy thing is he
really yeah i mean it's like joseph
joseph grossie oh my gosh jamona i am
looking for my joseph grossi he's out
there
[Laughter]
okay our next question is coming from
linda linda what is your question for
demona hi drew hi damona
i need help
okay i've been on and off dating apps
for the past two years
i'm middle aged and i would like to
settle down
the last date that i went on
the guy showed up looking 25 years older
than his profile picture
he lied about his profession he said he
was a doctor and he showed up with a
stethoscope in his pocket
and he lived in his office oh so my
question is how do i get better at
pre-screening and screening
so i don't get catfished again
oh i love this question
well first of all linda it's not in your
head there's two categories of catfish
there are the people who aren't really
confident in who they are which is what
you were dealing with and the people who
are have nefarious intentions who you
know want to scam you and take your
money so
i guess the the positive side is that we
didn't have that kind of catfish but the
negative side is it's just as it's
disappointing you've invested time and
you you had you know a hope that this
person was going to be who they said
they were so here's what i want you to
look out for next time
on the photos they have to be they have
to seem current if they're not crisp
digital quality like we're all carrying
high quality cameras in our pockets
every day there is no excuse for having
like a scanned photo or something that
looks like it's too far away or isn't
isn't really clear and you can always
ask for more more photos if you're not
really sure
also in those photos if they look posed
i'm not talking about like pose i'm
talking about like brochure level pose
that is a really big sign and especially
if they're in a uniform like you'll see
this a lot of times with doctors with
people in the with in um
with people in the armed services
so look out for those things if you if
your spidey senses go off and you feel
like oh i don't know about this picture
go and run it through a google image
search do you know how to do this just
in google you can go into the search bar
you can you can go up to image and you
can search a photo and see if it comes
up associated with anything else
anything that doesn't match with what
they've told you that's how i found out
he wasn't a doctor well there you go so
you want to do that before you get
invested and before you actually meet up
with this person another sign is that
they'll love bomb you they'll tell you
all of the things that you want to hear
they'll whisper sweet nothings into your
your inbox and then they if you step
back and you read
what they've said you realize it could
kind of be said to anybody it might not
be that specific that could be a sign of
the other kind of catfish also if those
those people don't want to meet up in
person or won't at least do a video date
now that is a primary
screening to get to the date to do a
video chat date and if they seem
squirrely about that
there's definitely something going on
linda what do you think i think
definitely helpful i don't know why i
didn't think of it myself
yeah exactly
and you are so stunning thank you like
you are the catch and i can see this
about you and it's funny when it comes
to ourselves all of a sudden we don't
have that same sort of fierce loyalty of
protection
so
you are so worth it you are so beautiful
inside and out and you are not alone i
swear i've gone through the same exact
things
um
just elusiveness uh too much mystery
i don't know where i stand i don't know
who i'm dealing with i totally have
dealt with the same thing on dating apps
so
let's try and figure this out
because it's not changing
[Music]